this is the giant garter snake  they are endemic to the central valley  wetlands of california and considered an  aquatic species but with the loss of  wetlands in the region the garda snake  is no longer found in 98 of the areas it  once resided in  [Music]  considered the largest of the garda  snake family they can grow to be more  than five feet long  [Music]  while they are venomous creatures they  pose no risk to humans  their mild venom subdues its prey which  consists mainly of fission frogs  these snakes are brown or olive coloured  but can easily be spotted by their  yellow stripes  are secretive and difficult to approach  and are known to dive into water before  an observer can get too close  [Music]  conservation efforts to create  artificial wetlands are underway to try  and restore their dwindling populations  this is the giant gardener snake  you